hey everyone cereth register nurse sorry
and calm and in this video i want to go
over some tips on how to deal with
patients who are afraid of needles so as
a nurse you are gonna encounter patients
who were just really terrified of
needles and this can affect both male or
female patients and from my personal
experience I have found that my male
patients tend to struggle with this a
little bit more than my female patients
for example I had the smell patient who
needed his IV changed out his other one
had expired so I go in there I get the
IV first stick and I'm sitting there
flushing it and I wasn't flushing it all
of a sudden the patient he just falls
back in the bed with his eyes closed and
I'm thinking oh no I think he might have
passed out and so I look up on the heart
monitor he still has a rhythm I feel his
pulse still has a pulse I'm trying to
keep my IV nice and secure because it's
not taped down yet because I'm just
flushing it and I'm like sir
are you okay and he opens his eyes he's
all pale he's like I'm really sorry but
I'm just super afraid of needles and I
should have let you know and another
time I was working at the VA and a
clinic drawing blood and a lot of the
patients that we would receive have been
in war they have killed people they've
seen blood and guts and they've been in
really really stressful traumatic
situations and some of the men before we
would actually draw their blood they
would request to be laid on a gurney
and one man absolutely told me
point-blank he's like listen do not even
show me that needle before you stick me
because he just did not want to see it
because it made him pass out so as you
can see this is a real issue that some
patients experience so as a nurse what
can you do to help these patients out
first what you want to do is you want to
see if your patient does have a phobia
of needles and how we can do that is you
can look at their body language when you
mention that you have to draw blood or
you have to start an IV on them because
a lot of times patients aren't just
going to tell you listen I'm afraid of
needles I don't like needles very rarely
will they do that because they don't
want to come off like they're weak or
something like that so whenever you do
tell them you have to
this procedure look at that body
language do they tense up do they look
away do they side to the cringe
something like that and I can tip you
off hey I need to be delicate with this
because this patient doesn't like this
we don't want to make their phobia worse
compared to patients who aren't really
afraid of needles you tell them what
you're gonna be doing they're like okay
when we gonna do it next you'll want to
ask your patient you know where would
you like me to draw your blood or start
your IV because a lot of these patients
know where the best place to draw blood
or get that vein in that first stick and
it usually causes them less pain and
they prefer that site so always just ask
them if they have a preference some
patients don't and some patients do and
another thing whenever I've had a
patient who has actually told me you
know I'm really afraid of the size of
the needle what size are you going to
use and if in that particular situation
I can use a smaller size needle let's
say like a 22 or a 23 because they're
not gonna be getting blood products or
they don't need it for like a special
procedure then I'll let them know yeah
I'm gonna use the smallest needle I can
on you the next size is almost like a
pediatric and I have found that that has
helped some patients whenever I let them
know that it is a smaller needle and
whenever you're getting out your
supplies and you're setting it up beside
the patient before you actually stick
them you want to take care and make sure
that if the patient is watching you a
lot of times patients who are afraid of
needles that are gonna look away and not
watch you but the ones who do watch you
you want to take care that they
understand that this huge saline flush
is not the needle that's going to be
poking them because I've actually had
patients look at me and say that's the
needle and I'm like oh no this is just a
saline flush there's not even a needle
on that in that IV packaging with the
actual needle in it can look bigger than
what it really is because it has the cap
over the IV and things like that so you
want to make sure that your patient
doesn't think that you're just using
this huge needle on them then said this
is just the packaging over the needle
now if you have a patient who is just
really struggling with the thought of
you you
and needle on them to draw blood or
start an IV or say this is like the
second or third time you have to stick
them because there are really hard stick
and it's causing them a lot of pain you
have options of obtaining an order for
some like numbing cream or a numbing
agent that will numb my skin
there's emilich cream that you put on
the side it takes about an hour for it
to actually numb the area so keep that
in mind or vape oh cool and or something
like that now in some facilities that
you may have a protocol standing you can
do that but in my experience I've only
had to do it once and I had to call the
doctor to get an order so you always
want to keep that in mind now when it
actually comes to giving that stick your
best tool as a nurse is distraction I
have found through all the times I have
stuck someone who's afraid of needles is
distraction it's my biggest tool and it
helps them and it helps me so what I do
is as I'm getting my supplies together
and I'm cleaning their side I am keeping
them in deep a dialogue about something
that is interesting to them not about
something that's fluffy like the weather
or something just random that you really
don't think much about you just have
this automatic response you want to talk
to them about their career some current
event that they're really interested in
have them talking deep to you because
the biggest thing that they're afraid of
is that initial stick of that needle
they aren't anticipating that pain and
they don't want that pain so if you're
keeping them distracted they're not
going to really know when it happens
because you're getting your supplies
your cleaning and everything so whenever
you go to stick I don't tell patients
whenever I'm fixing the stick I just
stick and then do my flush and
everything like that and a lot of times
I have found that as I'm flushing my me
whenever I'm done the patient will look
at me and say are you already done I'm
like yeah and just keeping their mind
distracted helped them a lot so I really
recommend that
so say you do have a patient that passes
out like my one patient or actually
screams out in pain while you're poking
them with the needle or they start
crying or something like that you want
to validate their feelings and you want
to
sure that you have your nonverbal body
language under control because you don't
want to sign or roll your eyes and
communicate to them that you think
they're just a big baby or something
like that because you can make their
phobia worse and make them feel
inadequate so just always make sure that
you let them know that you know I've had
other patients that have had issues with
this as well so you're not the only
person and finally say that you're a new
nurse and you just don't have your IV
skills and you're drawing blood skills
really polished up yet you still need
experience which is totally normal
because whenever a lot of new nurses
start out they're just not good at IVs
are drawing blood until they get
experience and they do it day in and day
out and you have this patient who
literally does not like needles and
they've told you point Mike you only get
one
stick well if you're like me when it
arrives a new nurse whatever a patient
told me that I'm thinking well I'm
definitely probably not gonna get it
first job because you told me only get
one stick and that's just made me more
nervous so you probably what you want to
do in that type of situation is you want
to seek out a more experienced nurse and
ask them if they wouldn't care
getting this IV for you because the
patient is afraid of needles and they
only are gonna allow one stick and to
help sweeten the deal for another nurse
you can tell them hey what do you need
done I can do this for you if you can do
this for me too like a trade-off so um
do that in those type of situations if
that does happen but as you get
experience and as time goes by you won't
want to get someone else to do it for
you you'll want to do it yourself
because you've got to get experience
okay so those are some tips on how to
deal with those patients who are afraid
of needles thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos